welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Johannes Aqua Johannes is a
researcher at Founders pledge where he
leads the climate change fund Johannes
welcome to the podcast thanks so much
for having me G great to be here I'm big
fan of future of Life Institute and yeah
happy to talk all things climate today
perhaps we could start with your role at
Founders pledge what is it that you do
there how do you how do you see your
role yeah so I think the way I usually
describe it as like um my goal and and
the goal of my my team is kind of to
like find um and fund kind of the
highest impact opportunities in climate
and those are like philanthropic
opportunities right so like things where
we can or a million dollars or something
in that order of magnitude can kind of
Make a Difference by supporting
initiatives that are like extremely
promising and yeah as you mentioned kind
of in the beginning right so there's
kind of the the climate fund which kind
of puts this um
to Li the founders climate fund but also
we're advising kind of high Networth
individuals kind of beyond that and kind
of trying to yeah trying to identify
using research and using prioritization
research kind of to identify where where
are the biggest PL spot what are the pl
spot generating mechanisms if you will
and kind of what does that mean for what
you should fund on a margin as as an
next philanthropist yeah and I think
that word is the key so thinking on the
margin here I see your job or I think
that that your job is about
thinking about the marginal dollar where
is that dollar best spent would that be
the correct frame yes uh the next dollar
or the next million dollar and I think
that's like a really really um crucial
frame because I think a lot of the
things that I I'm going to be saying is
going to be like controversial and might
be wrong if like if one would interpret
them as in like this is all we should be
doing and that's I'm not really talking
about this is all what should be doing
we should I'm talking about like at the
margin this is what we should be doing
relatively relatively more of yeah we're
going to go get into a broad overview of
the whole climate change issue we're
going to look at all the potential
Technologies or government options that
might help us alleviate this problem but
I think we should start with your
personal Journey as an environmentalist
so how did you end up in this role where
did you start when did you first become
interested in the climate so I mean I
grew up in the '90s in Germany so it was
very easy to kind of become an
environmentalist I think so kind of in
my I remember like some of my first
childhood memories kind of being very
interested and and saving the tiger so
it's like inventing a board game save
the Siberian tiger kind of like and like
yeah there was a an animal documentary
on like three times a week and like the
last five or 10 minutes of the
documentary would always be like okay
and now humans are are destroying this
beautiful nature right so that that was
kind of um I think very big part um of
kind of yeah of this of this I think
initial initial education or becoming an
environmentalist and I guess I got more
serious about this kind of yeah in my in
my teenage years when I was like an
environmental activist for the German
chapter of um friends of the earth and
kind of like protesting President Bush
to sign the Kyoto Protocol when he was
visiting this kind of stuff so that's
kind of where it started and then I kind
of when it came to to University I think
the idea for me was okay let's kind of
study social sciences with the focus on
like understanding what's kind of what
kind of makes um climate policies
successful so that's kind of what I
spent kind of my my studies on and then
I was working afterwards uh for for a
think tank in Germany for five years
kind of working on carbon pricing and
that's kind of ultimately after this
kind of joint joint Founders pledge kind
of went into philanthropy so that's kind
of um the story yeah and and what's
something you've changed your mind about
where where have you gotten new ideas or
learned new f that kind of changed your
priorities I mean lots lots and lots
over the years right so that was kind of
like a very short introduction to like a
20e journey I think the first big change
was probably in in college kind of so at
that point I was kind of yeah very
strongly kind of yeah as I said like
influenced by the environmental movement
kind of was kind of card carrying
environmentalist if you will and
essentially at that point kind of yeah
as I said I was kind of studying social
science we kind of focusing on on
political culture and
understanding in a way that like the
things that I believed or the kind of
people like me would believe about how
to solve the climate change right so
like heavily focused on Renewables
heavily focused on Energy Efficiency
heavily focused on lifestyle change
being anti-nuclear being somewhat
skeptical of technological innovation
right that essentially all of those
beliefs kind of fit together kind of in
a very systematic fashion right and what
unites them is not that they're kind of
an adequate response to the climate
challenge what unites them is that
they're kind of part of a specific
ideology in this kind this case kind of
like a kind of egalitarian green um
ideology which kind of is is framing a
large part of the climate conversation
so I think that was kind of the first
really important realization that like
all of all of the responses to the
climate and other problems are kind of
heavily ideological shaped right like if
you have a situation like we in climate
which is kind of dominated by one kind
of ideology this will kind of shape the
shape the results so so I think that was
kind of one I think another one a bit
later when I was studying in the in the
United States this was like
2012 2011 2012 this was the time where
essentially in the US kind of the big
push the big push um under Obama to kind
of push for climate policy Waxman Mary
was the name so like kind of a c and
trade bill in the United States kind of
had just failed right and this was like
a once in a generation moment with
regards to uh climate policy in the US
right so like the Democrats had like won
the presidency had like huge majority in
the house and the in the Senate as well
right so like was kind of a situation of
Reckoning like what are we going to do
now because like even even under such
favorable conditions that we kind of can
expect any every like 15 or 20 years
like we're not able to pass climate
policy in the US so I think in that time
kind of discovered kind of I think what
what I would describe is kind of like
the Innovation Hawk argument in climate
right so like people that I like very
heavily focused um on Innovation which I
think at that time was kind of not not
that big a part of the of the climate um
coalitions I think that's kind of
another thing that changed around that
time U I don't think I go all the way
but it's kind of interesting so because
in a way what they did or what they were
emphasizing kind of became a big part of
climate policy that later passed so like
that that's just passed with President
Biden is kind of essentially putting
this lots of those ideas into practice
but so another one and then I think
another kind of big one of course um for
me growing up as a German
environmentalist I was heavily
antinuclear and and being in the S also
it's the first time kind of exposed to
to pronuclear environmentalists and for
a time was kind of lukewarm about
nuclear and at some point kind of
realized okay even though it's very
uncomfortable in the German context
because otherwise reasonable people
become like very unreasonable and very
emotionally aggressive like when you're
talking about nuclear and when you're
being nuclear but that was kind of an
important uh shift of mind as well I
think those are kind of
three and then two more recent ones um I
would say uh
2015 um essentially the success of the
Paris agreement so up until
2015 I think International climate
policy by and large had always failed um
this was kind of like the expectations
were very low and then um the fact that
the Paris agreement kind of succeeded
even though it's kind of a non-binding
agreement but it kind of has completely
changed the conversations that we're
having in different countries so it kind
of it serves as this kind of um
Northstar that kind of lots of national
conversations are kind of focused on so
I think that's kind of was another
surprise the way in what sense did the
Paris agreement succeed what what have
been the results of it I mean the Paris
agreement has succeeded I mean not only
the Paris agreement but like around that
time so like that was in late 2015 and
then like 2016 2017 the nature of the
climate conversation has completely
changed right like around that time in
in Western countries anyway in the sense
that like before it was kind of a
relatively Niche issue and it kind of
became like a broad societal consensus
that like meeting the goals of the Paris
agreement matters I mean it's maybe not
a political consensus across the
political aisle in all countries but at
least kind of for the left the center
left kind of in all countries so so I
think that kind of um really change and
kind of the idea of of Net Zero and that
climate was kind of a top issue yeah so
I think that's kind of I think what the
Paris agreement achieved right and like
this is kind of very significant like
compared right it's like it's a
non-binding treaty ultimately so there
there is a version I think you could
have had a cynical take on this
agreement kind of before like it's not
and and I certainly had this to a degree
like it's not going to do much because
it's like a non-binding very weak
agreement and on some level that's true
um so that's not what it's doing what
it's doing it's kind of like
transforming transforming the
conversation and you you mentioned a a
last thing that you changed your mind on
I think the last thing that I would
mention was kind of that I think that's
kind of maybe like 2020 or so
essentially that um the situation around
climate has improved very very
significantly which is kind of funny to
say this because I think most people
have the have the opposite perception
but like in general that like so like in
2015 2016 people were saying things like
there's a 5% probability of some of more
of six degrees or more warming and I
think right now if you would make this
forecast the the forecast right now
would be something like it's maybe like
half a percent that we get to to 60
degrees at all and not more than six
degrees so like an order of magnitude
change and so essentially
that the forecast before were probably
bit pessimistic but also that the
situation kind of has has changed very
significantly mostly through the success
of Renewables the success of kind of
electric cars that essentially the the
very high risk climate Futures are
essentially almost ruled out at this
point and that's a very significant um
change I'm wondering when you're working
with climate change this is such a
complex issue it's it's a it involves a
lot of disciplines not just climate
science itself but economics and law and
the physics and engineering and all of
these disciplines how is how do you form
an all things considered view of the
situation in light of all of these
disciplines I mean you can't go get a a
PhD in all of them I'm guessing and so
how do you yeah how do you how do you
approach this I mean in theory you could
but by the time you have those phds the
problem is solved um yeah so I think the
answer here I mean has to be to kind of
essentially you're always in the state
of like kind of being um a reviewer and
kind of like a reviewer of different
pieces of evidence so that's like one
piece of the answer another piece of the
answer is kind of obviously you do this
on a team right so like um essentially
right now um in my team like we have a
specialist kind of for the
technoeconomics we have a specialist for
Carlock and emerging economies we have a
specialist for for philanthropy and how
other philanthropists behave so that's
kind of another piece of the answer but
to I think to answer it more
substantively I think there's kind of
like three kinds of expertise that are
like most significant when it comes to
the question of like that I'm trying to
answer which is like what should we be
doing philanthropically right so which
is kind of um like only one way to to
answer the question but there I think
it's kind of like one is kind of really
the social science question of like
political visability like which kind of
like carbon taxes can we get where which
kind of policies can we achieve in a
given country so that's kind of like
what does the option space um actually
look like so that's kind of I think the
one key expertise the other one is kind
of like what do different policies or
different kind of things in the world
what do they achieve right so like
that's I guess policy analysis and
econometrics and stuff like that and
then there's kind of because climate
change is really a decadal challenge and
a global Challenge and like it's also a
challenge about global technological
transformation so then there's kind of
this question of like what do changes in
in countries kind of what are the
long-term consequences of that and kind
of changing the technology stack if you
will globally so to technoeconomic
question and I think think those three
expertises I kind of the most um most
relevant ones um from a from a solution
oriented perspective and then of course
if you're a philanthropist like myself
then also like what are other
philanthropists doing right because like
doing the best thing on the margin is
almost always about kind of finding PL
spots and filling the pl spots okay so
let's get to this broad overview that I
would like of of climate change on the
broadest possible scale what is it that
driving climate change is it mostly
emissions and if so where are these
emissions coming from so it's like
mostly mostly emissions right and so
like all of the I mean all of climate
change is is about emissions and so if
you kind of I mean there's different
ways to slice it but I guess let's first
kind of slice it by sector so if you
kind of look at it by sector then
there's like 75% of emissions are
related to kind of um energy and energy
here like one very important thing about
climate electricity is only a small part
of energy electricity is about a third
of energy so like when they say 75%
that's not only electricity right that's
also kind of Transport fuels that's um
heating fuels and that's also stuff like
industrial heat essentially the burning
of fossil fuels uh to produce energy so
that's about 75% of emissions then
there's about 5% of emissions that's
kind of um emissions from industrial
processes so stuff like producing cement
or chemicals where you kind of have
emissions that are not related to fossil
fuels that are called process emissions
right and that doesn't mean that
industry is only 5% this is about the
kind of the the non-energy share of
Industry so that together gets you to
like about
80% and then there's about 15 or like
18% that's kind of related to to
agricultural emissions um broadly and
then the last 5% or so is kind of um a
combination of on the one hand stuff
like deforestation
and on the other hand stuff like waste
so yeah I think 80 80% of the challenge
is kind of energy energy industry
there's two important uh qualifications
to this this is kind of where the
emissions are coming from right now
right and like that doesn't mean that
this is exactly proportional to what the
solution looks like so like it can
definitely be the case that kind of um
land use change and kind of like
restoring Wilderness Etc it's like a
bigger part of the of the solution py I
think that's kind of one qualification
and another qualification is that these
percentages are kind of heavily
dependent on what um warming metric you
use so the the numbers that I cited
right now are kind of for what's called
global warming potential 100 so like if
we're kind of assuming over the course
um of a 100 years if you kind of take a
shorter view if you would say something
like global warming potential for the
next 20 years then something like
agriculture would have like a larger
share because meane which is a very
potent greenhouse gas in the short term
has kind of a relatively larger share in
agriculture than in other sectors so
that's another important qualification
here yeah and in in in global terms are
emissions still increasing yes and how
how how for how long do we expect them
to increase well I mean people have been
talking about the end to emission
increase for for for a long time and
then there's always something um
something else coming up so I think we
will probably see the end to increasing
emissions this decade um so I me it's
mostly dependent on what China and India
doing at this point and they're both
kind of yeah have the goal to kind of
peak their emissions rather soon so it
could happen um could happen this decade
Yeah you mentioned China and India we
should talk about geographically where
emissions are coming from where where
have they come from in the past and
where are they likely to come from in
the future well so I think in the past
rate um if you kind of Take the Long
View then indust like um most of the
emissions are certainly like have been
caused by by Western countries I think
that's that's kind of clear and like we
do have uh being in Western countries
like a large historical
responsibility but if we kind of look at
the situation right now like the us
right now something like 15% of
emissions the EU is something around
like
10% and like Asia is kind of something
like close to two-thirds of emissions
and then kind of the rest and if we kind
of think this picture going forward
right so like the share of the EU and
the share of the us is going to going to
further decre decrease I mean probably
to something like for the US to
something like 5% for like um the EU
maybe something like
3% and then uh yeah China is going to be
something like 25% I think over over the
course of the century then other other
emerging Asia kind of India then
southeast Asia and then kind of at some
point later in the century Africa um
hopefully we'll hopefully will will grow
strongly and like I mean yeah let's hope
it's going to be low carbon but like I
guess there there's kind of that's kind
of also part of the um the long game so
like the emissions are very clearly the
focus of emissions is very much changing
right that's kind of what I sometimes
call like the central conundrum of
climate policy which is like the people
that are responsible for a lot of the
historical emissions kind of have very
little direct leverage and kind of how
bad the the problem is going to become
because kind of essentially in the EU
like there's not a lot of emissions you
can reduce like I mean anymore right
like I mean already kind of reaching the
goal of getting to carbon neutrality by
2050 is like very ambitious but at that
point like there's there's no leverage
left because you project that EU is only
going to be 3% of emissions and so
reducing emissions by 3% would be great
but it's not going to tackle the problem
in a big way essentially most of the
leverage that the EU has on emissions
does not come from the own territorial
emissions right so if we kind of look at
the most significant things that EU
countries have done it's like things
like Denmark making wind energy cheap
Germany kind of making solar cheap these
these kind of things have like done way
way more to like transform the energy
future than like emission changes within
Europe European countries have
subsidized technologies that can then be
exported to other countries where they
can decrease emissions much more than
they could in those European countries
themselves from what you're saying the
the biggest problem or the biggest
driver of emission is energy production
I wonder if if that category is too
broad I mean a lot of things must must
be covered by energy production is it
what what does that category cover yeah
so like I think yeah I mean it covers
kind of um electricity it covers heating
it covers transport and it also covers I
mean stats also heating but kind of very
different than what we mean when we say
heating like stuff like industrial heat
right which is like steel and stuff like
that and like on some level it's kind of
true broad a term I still find it useful
to think about as kind of One Piece
because especially if we're thinking
about kind of the solution trajectory
right so like what like I guess the
master plan plan and so far is there is
the master plan to kind of solve climate
right is essentially um Electrify
everything uh or like I mean Electrify
all energy consumption right so in that
sense like historically those factors
have been very different but like or
kind of also very different in terms of
the fuels but like you want to get in a
situation where like the central problem
is is one of kind of on the one hand
getting electricity or energy production
kind of low or zero carbon and on the
other hand kind of either directly right
with electric cars or indirectly through
stuff like hydrogen um electrifying kind
of a lot of other stuff so in that sense
it's it's a cross simplification to
speak of like energy as one sector but
it's also I think if we're kind of at
the broad level it's it's a useful one
in terms of um yeah in terms of the
solution landscape yeah so so so the
categor is kind of unified by the same
solution the same solution would solve
all of the the the things that belong to
that category so electrification would
be a solution for many of of of the
things that belong to that category or
is that too strong I mean it's just a
little bit too strong but I think it's
kind of right and the yeah basically
right I would say right so so how far
electrification goes kind of depends on
like like things are differentially easy
to Electrify so like things that are
hard to Electrify is stuff that kind of
requires I mean either a long duration
of storage or like lots of kind of
concentrated energy or so like stuff
like heavy duty transport right like
electrifying trucks is much harder than
electrifying passenger cars and like
electrifying lar or like decarbonizing
large ships is kind of much harder and
airplanes much harder than cars so and
for some of those um you might either
use kind of indirect electrification
right so kind of like hydrogen or using
power to create hydrogen but it might
also go another way you can also kind of
create the hydrogen kind of with natural
gas and carbon capture and storage yeah
so so there there that's kind of where
there is um more more Nuance there we
can kind of Dive Dive deeper why is it
more difficult to Electrify an airplane
than a car is it is it because the
airplane will have will have a need for
higher Peak energy output or something
like that well it's essentially I mean
batteries are very heavy and so like an
airplane becomes much more efficient
because once you burn the fuel it's kind
of not it has no weight anymore um and
it's also so like that's kind of one
part and like the other part is kind of
like energy energy density right so like
in principle like flying and air like
flying kind of requires a lot of like
it's kind of much harder than kind of
moving moving a car around and so you
kind of need
need higher energy density okay so what
I want to do is is to walk through all
of the potential technological options
we have start with that I'm going to
start with talking about oil and coal
which is kind of a funny place to start
maybe because in that in some sense oil
and coal is is the whole reason for the
problem but I think it's interesting to
discuss oil and coal just because if we
know something about why they are hard
to replace we might know something about
uh how to how to best go about the
climate change problem so yeah i' I've
written down that that oil and coal is
cheap and it works in in existing
systems and do you see other advantages
Beyond those I just mentioned yeah I
think those are kind of the the
two really big ones right and like work
in existing systems I think another way
to put this is like we've essentially
build an entire world economy around
them so they fit with existing systems
because we built an entire economy
around around them and not only in
economy right like the United States was
kind of having aircraft carriers in the
Persian Gulf because kind of protecting
oil reserves is kind of part of the well
it's like part of the overall kind of
strategy right so it's like yeah um
essentially we've been spending more
than a centry optimizing our energy and
World economy for relying on oil coal
natural gas I think another kind of
advantage that they do have I mean at
least if we compare them to Renewables
um to most Renewables is that they do
have um higher energy densities so um
yeah and then of course um I mean in the
case of oil right like oil is easy to
transport uh coal is also relatively
easy to transport with gas it's it's a
bit harder yeah so I think this is kind
of what like broadly speaking that's
that seems like the right
characterization and of course the
enormous disadvantage here is that
there's very high emissions associated
with uh oil and coal and I I think
additionally there are there are quite
large problems with air pollution which
provides us with an additional reason to
replace oil and Co maybe you could talk
about air pollution from from oil and
coal how big of a problem is that so air
pollution at large kills about 7 million
people every year uh so it's like one of
the leading causes of death and not all
of that is related to fossil fuels right
so like you also have the situation that
some of that is actually related to
Renewables so like to um especially in
Africa people burning wood for heating
at home and for for cooking so that
that's actually a situation where like
using a fossil fuel in this case natural
gas would actually be much better
because it um but essentially so um in
particular coal and oil kind yeah yeah
kill kill a lot of people so gas is a
lot cleaner SO gas is about 15 times
cleaner than coal in terms of um air
pollution but it's a very significant
cause of death and I think it's also
really underappreciated so like people
usually talk about air pollution as kind
of like a co- benefit of climate change
and like climate change has to get
really bad to kill like five million
people every year like right so like
it's kind of quite possible that we
solving climate change and like the most
significant effect of that is kind of a
reduction kind of um air pollution
casualties right obviously like this is
not the highest risk case right like
there are cases with there's no case
with air pollution like killing 100
million people right and there's kind of
cases there's risk cases around climate
that kind of motivate caring about
climate that are that are more extreme
than killing five million million people
but like yeah it's just just I guess
it's it's not it's not a co- benefit
it's kind of a problem on on a similar
order of magnitude yeah makes sense air
pollution is a huge deal why is it that
oil and gas is hard to replace and here
we might talk about a carbon lockin also
which is a term that that that's used
the primary reason and if like energy
transitions are well energy transitions
are hard for a couple of reasons right
but like okay let's let's kind of start
with the with a lock in reason to begin
with a lot of the assets right like
pipelines uh or coal power plants or
highways Etc right like those are very
long lift assets right they have natural
lifetimes that are like 40 or 60 years
they're Capital intensive assets so like
even if like you're kind of in a
situation where like every new build is
kind of the low carbon alternative it
would take you like 40 years to kind of
turn around like an entire system right
and that's kind of um an optimistic case
so like it's like there's a lot of kind
of lock in and then there's so like this
is kind of at the pure kind of technical
or infrastructural level right and then
you also have stuff like uh like
pipelines and infrastructure which are
which are even even longer longer lift
and than single assets and then of
course you have like a huge kind of
political economy like political special
interest kind of groups and kind of the
entire kind of fate of country is
essentially built around that right I
guess like when people say like Putin
used to behave like a the CE CEO of like
a gas company right like I mean kind of
changed a little bit the way he's
behaving but like right like it's kind
of like uh like their entire countries
or entire kind of regions of the world
that are like heavily dependent on on
the fossil fuel um economy so I think
that's kind of another um really big
reason um and another reason of like
obviously is also like energy
transitions in general move towards
denser forms of energy right so like
what we're trying to do right now where
we're essentially saying okay we want to
move from a fossil fuel dominated energy
economy to one that's kind of dominated
by Renewables it's kind of not a natural
direction for an energy transition uh to
go so like the the more natural
direction of energy transitions thus far
has been like from less energy dense
fuel stuffff like from biomass to fossil
fuels right and like going from fossil
fuels to mostly mostly renewable powered
systems actually it's not a natural um
move of the Energy System it probably
wouldn't happen like there are many
other situations where it kind of
wouldn't wouldn't happen yeah maybe here
is is a a natural point to talk about
energy density why is energy density
important so energy density right so
like essentially how much land and how
many resources do you need to kind of
produce a given amount of energy so the
reason that's important I think is kind
of like twofold I mean from an
environmental perspective energy density
is essentially a proxy for like how much
uh impact do we have on the environment
right so if you're using less land if
you're using less materials then you're
kind of like in principle like lower
energy density means like lower
environmental impact so that's kind of
one one part of it the other part which
is more about like what's useful for for
for human civilization right so like
having denser forms of energy like if
you're talking about electricity it
means like you need less transmission
for example right so like that's kind of
another use and you're also kind of if
you want to power like indust an
industrial center or like an urbanizing
Society like having lots of
energy and having relatively dense forms
of energy is useful when shouldn't
overdo this right it's like I'm not
saying like on the limit kind of we
would have like one big Fusion plant and
we all kind of just get from so that's
clearly not the case I think we've seen
this with nuclear fision that like
having very large kind of energy sources
also has its downside because demand
isn't always there so like not take it
to the extreme limit but like kind of on
some level like energy density in
principle is kind of a useful a useful
metric but when you when you're talking
about energy density it's you're talking
about also the resources necessary to
produce that energy not only the energy
density say for example of a 10 cm by 10
CM cube of coal or oil or fuel for for a
nuclear reactor it's a broader term than
that that's energy density where we've
historically been moving towards forms
of energy that are that are more dense
and now we're trying to move towards
forms of energy that are that are less
dense I think before we get to
Renewables we should we should talk
about natural gas that that you
mentioned a couple of times and what are
the advantages here and and the
disadvantages I'm guessing it's it's uh
better than oil and coal just to add on
the energy density like because we've
talked about why it's important but we
didn't talk about what does it actually
look like so like uh if you're kind of
if if you look at the metrix right
nuclear nuclear power would be something
like s terawatt hours per square
kilometers uh natural gas which we're
going to talk about next it's like about
half that and like solar is kind of
about hundreds or so roughly what
nuclear is right so that's kind of why
it matters like the differences are are
quite Star both from from Renewables to
to fossil fuels and from fossil fuels to
to nuclear like natural gas if we talk
about natural gas so I mean it's about
half as polluting um as coal in terms of
CO2 and it's much much less polluting
about 15 times less polluting when we
talk about air pollution and essentially
if you look at the decarbonization
successes of the last 20 years like many
of them have been cold to gas
transitions so like essentially the fact
that the US was kind of able to reduce
emissions even though until like 2021
didn't really have much in terms of
climate policy it's like mostly the
story of the fracking revolution in the
United States and kind of the the
replacement of coal by natural gas a
little bit similar in the UK in the UK
there's kind of natural gas is also like
more of a renewable expansion um and
that so like that's kind of another so
like that's kind of it has been a big
story it's like an easy win right it's
not a transformational win because you
don't get to zero emissions but it's
kind of the easy win so if you're
imposing moderate carbon price in a
place with a lot of coal that will
usually mean you're going to substitute
it for natural gas in which cases does
it make sense to switch to natural gas I
mean that's kind of like right that
that's kind of I think something where
the climate Community has like two
different perspectives right I think
there are people that are more
incrementalist that would say like yeah
it's good if you're switching from coal
to Natural Gas there's also people that
would say okay if you're switching from
coal to Natural Gas you're locking in
another fossil fuel source right and
it's kind of like better to maybe have
coal run a bit longer and then fully
replace it with a zero carbon Source I
think that's kind of the debate and I
think different people have like
different opinions and I think also the
right answer might be different and
different places the best case scenario
would be one for like natural gas
replaces coal and then natural gas is
kind of replaced with natural gas gas
and Caron carbon capture so where you're
kind of capping the emissions or we
using kind of part of the natural gas
infrastructure with like zero carbon
fuels right so like with um natural gas
kind of that's produced um for
electrolysis and kind of like additional
like adding CO2 there or yeah so
synthetic um natural gas essentially so
that last point is there a way to
produce natural gas that's more
environmentally friendly so I mean
natural gas is just CH4 so in principle
you can um you can get it from H2 like
from hydrogen uh like which you can
generate a low carbon way and if you
would kind of then take CO2 out of the
air so you kind of potentially produce
like carbon neutral natural gas right
like this uh yeah or you could use
hydrogen um yeah yeah so so essentially
there there's ideas about using some of
the kind of natural gas infrastructure
for like zero carbon gases yeah so
that's I think something like one way
where carbon lock in can be made a
little bit less severe right where
you're like locking in like a gas
infrastructure for example but that gas
could at some point be be carbon neutral
yeah if we build a new new natural gas
plant now how much carbon are we lcking
in for how many years would this natural
gas plant have to run in order to be
profitable or to make sense to build if
you're building new natural gas plants
right now I think the expect like most
like if you're in a western country I
don't think the investor would have the
expectation that they're going to run
this for 40 years because like running
this for 40 years would mean we're now
2023 so like 13 years after uh kind of
most Western countries have committed to
like reaching at zero that being said
right like even countries like Germany
um that are kind of priding themselves
to be climate leaders are are building
new natural gas uh capacity right now in
an in an energy crisis situation right
so we're essentially I guess the way
this becomes profitable is because we
really do value energy security So like
um as countries we're we're willing to
kind of finance things that don't make
sense in a in a long run perspective if
you will maybe we could say a bit more
about energy density and and why it's
important is it important because some
forms of energy take up too much space
and then crowd out other other things we
would like to do with that space like
having natural habitats or yeah using
the land for agriculture or what what's
the problem with energy sources with low
energy density so like crowding out of
um like other land uses is definitely um
a factor right so especially for for
biofuels I think it's a it's a factor
like biofuels take up a lot of land and
like kind of agricultural land that that
can compete with like food security
concerns yeah so I think that is kind of
uh one concern so like land use right so
like I've looked at a paper where
essentially that's kind of modeling a
transition towards a lower carbon future
and what they're essentially like and
like a renewable heavy future what
they're essentially modeling is like
okay by
2050 there is an sixfold increase and
and the land require required for energy
production compared to today and like to
be fair like it's not that it's six
times less efficient because also like
electricity production is like assumed
to Triple over the time frame right so
that's kind of a halfing of like
efficiency in terms of like energy
density that's it's like still a
significant change I think to me the
more the more fundamental challenge is
really one of like if you're having lots
of decentralized energy sources like
kind of the requirements in terms of
transmission and like infrastructure
build out are kind of like much much
larger right so essentially when we're
saying it is cheap and it is easy to
build Renewables what we're talking
about is kind of on the plant level
where this is true but when we're
talking about the Energy System level
and say like we want to build an energy
system that is primarily based on low
energy density sources like I'm not
saying this cannot work but like this is
like a risky proposition mostly for the
for transmission and and storage um
requirements that are kind of you
related related to low energy density
and intermittency okay so that's oil
coal and natural gas um what about if we
if we get into the Renewables so solar
and wind what are some advantages of of
solar and wind at this point solar and
wind are pretty cheap so at this point I
think in many in many places in the
world it will be the case that like
adding solar capacity to the grid is
like one of the cheapest things you can
do it's very important to realize is
that like this is not a fact of like
nature or like technology itself that's
that's a result of like very conscious
social choices right I mean it's
essentially countries like Germany and
jurisdictions like California and then
then later kind of China uh essentially
saying okay we really want to have cheap
Renewables and we're really like heavily
investing that so in that sence kind of
the fact that we have cheap Renewables
right now is much more a function of
their popularity with constituencies
than it is kind of of like the principle
underlying technology right so like if
if like nuclear would be as popular as
like Renewables are we probably also
could have like cheap nuclear now kind
of what I'm saying um or a geothermal
for that matter so I think that's kind
of an important aspect here so yeah
there there can be quite cheap and also
there there are use cases where where
decentralized and kind of smaller
production is kind of good right so I
mean you can kind of um use deploy them
um where they are needed right you like
if you're um if you're a small town
you're not going to build your own kind
of big um Power Plant but you can build
your put your solar on the rooftop Etc
so I think that's kind of the main
advantage obviously produces no carbon
uh no air pollution um yeah and can be
can be built quickly yeah so you
mentioned that that solar and wind have
gotten cheaper because of basically
policies by European countries and by
California and so on when when solar has
reached the price point that it has that
it that it's at now does it require kind
of continual subsidies to to stay at
that price point or have we developed
solar to a point now that it's it's
price competitive even on an open market
let's say so in energy you generally
don't have open markets I think that's
an important thing to to to realize so
solar is competitive in many cases right
but like it's not like with oil where
like you have a global price of oil
right it's like essentially for solar
like how how cost effective solar
compared to Alternatives depend depends
on like how good is the solar resource
depends also on like how much solar is
already on the grid because like you can
be in a situation where like installing
the additional solar capacity is very
cheap but it's not going to produce a
lot of additional value because
essentially like the sun is shining at
the time where you're already at 100%
solar then like it's easy to add an
additional solar power power plant but
kind of it doesn't add a lot unless you
kind of have cheap storage or cheap
transmission super cheap uh storage
super cheap transmission
uh so that's that's what's called value
deflation so it's not really like it
doesn't really make sense to think about
it as like one price point uh that that
is being being undercut right so like
we're in a situation where there are
places in the world where like adding
solar kind of happens without subsidies
and it's kind of like essentially the
natural result of like Market forces or
like mediated Market forces and we have
also places with quite High renewable
penetration right places like California
or Germany where like places that made
Renewables so cheap but that are now
kind of struggling to add a lot more
because stuff like system integration or
like the value of an additional um plant
is kind of um is kind of low how much of
our energy production could we replace
by wind and solar alone the the problem
with wind and solar or one problem is
that it's intermittent so it it requires
the sun to shine or the wind to blow
unless you have a really good uh storage
technology basically batteries
but how how much of our energy
production do you think we could replace
by by solar and wind you don't only need
batteries right so like essentially you
need to solve I think three or four
problems so like one is kind of
shortterm storage for this you can use
batteries uh and right that's that's
kind of like okay you can run your
washing machine during the night that
that's kind of the use case then you
kind of need to solve in most places in
the world you need to solve seasonal
storage right so that there's kind of
like parts of the Year where like
there's much less solar available and
like that's like a much much harder
Challenge and I think that's kind of
underappreciated because people talk
about storage they think about batteries
and they think the problem was solved
but like kind of essentially being able
to have enough energy to like have a
month or like more kind of worth of like
energy Reserve requires a very different
um solution it's not probably not going
to happen with batteries that's kind of
we're something like right what I've
talked about before like power to X like
producing hydrogen or kind of other
forms of like um low carbon um energy um
like gases or like liquid to store
energy so like that's kind of what you
will need there and then there's kind of
the problem of transmission and then
there's the problem around essentially
do we have enough land um in the
jurisdictions um I think the last one
will not be the decisive constraint I
think that that will will probably work
but essentially there's like three uh
three challenges like storage in the
short term seasonal storage
transmission I can't imagine the world
right if when I think about the future I
always try to think of a distribution
and like there there's like part of that
distribution where like okay wind and
solar um are kind of really like 80 or
90% of the energy Supply and essentially
seasonal storage has been solved
transmission has been solved and it's
kind of that that's a large part of the
solution uh those are not the Futures
I'm particularly worried about because I
mean those are really very very best
case future is it's like an AI safety of
like AGI is inherently safe that's kind
of the the future uh and then they are
kind of the Futures where like something
has gone wrong right and like that's
kind of like in our climate response and
like a natural thing I think like one of
the most likely failure modes right now
that we can like if we kind of if we're
kind of waking up in 2040 and like we're
in a trajectory to like more than three
degrees it's very likely that kind of
we've been over betting on intermittent
Renewables essentially that it is much
harder even though it's easy to get to
like 20 30% in electricity like getting
to like 100% in energy right again like
and then like growing demand like
something like 10x compared now that
this is kind of um really hard so this
is an area where there's very
significant uncertainty I would say
where kind of yeah on the top you can
kind of do get almost 100% but also
where it's kind of quite imaginable that
you don't get over over 50% of energy
which would still be like huge huge huge
role right I mean right now it's kind of
something like three to 4% of like
energy you mentioned seasonal storage
what what are the most promising
approaches there um this is something
where it's not primarily about batteries
right so where it's primarily about kind
of uh using more energy dense form so
like for example yeah using um using
kind of excess capacity Excess power
capacity to produce carbon neutral
hydrogen to store this as hydrogen or to
kind of store it as like synthetic
natural gas this to me seems right now
the most
plausible trajectory I mean there's also
kind of I guess there's there's lots of
different technologies that are that are
being tried out okay so that's that's
solar and wind which could turn out very
very well but where there are challenges
to be solved before they can be
implemented and can constitute a large
percent of of our energy production that
sounds too pessimistic it's more like
solar and wi will definitely play a much
larger role than they are playing now
the question is will they take us to 100
% but like um yeah that's a yeah it's a
different framing right so like yeah the
short-term story is definitely about the
expansion of um of mature Renewables we
should say something about the to my
eyes insane decrease in in in the price
of Solar or at least it looks like a
very very uh steep decrease when I look
at these graphs yeah can you say
something about how much cheaper solar
is now compared to 20 years ago well
it's essentially at like less than 10%
of where it was 20 years ago right so
like that's uh that is an insane
decrease so I like I remember when I was
kind of entering the climate
conversation and people were talking
about Renewables they were always
talking about solar wind
geothermal Hydro bio at some point
people only started talking about solar
and wind right because essentially those
Technologies got like radically cheaper
in particular solar wind also but a bit
less so yeah so that's a very very steep
um decline right which has been achieved
uh there's there's a great book about
this how solar got cheap um by Gregory
nemit but essentially it's kind of
primarily a result of kind of very
aggressive um policy I mean it kind of
goes back to the 1970s and like the
first oil crisis and like Jimmy Carter
but then kind of got really picked up in
the early 2000s right of like Germany
kind of really strongly supporting it
also like not only Germany also like
California Etc and then like at some
point china essentially massively
investing uh in in production capacity
so yeah that's kind of of um a big part
of the of the story as well it's not a
story of fundamental technological
innovation it's really more of a PR
Force um approach to making things cheap
what about Hydro could Hydro ever
constitute a large per of of our energy
production so Hydro could I think I mean
it's like it's already I think it's
still if I'm not mistaken it's still
like the largest um renewable energy uh
resource right it's kind of it's not
really talked about because it's kind of
like static it's not like the it's not
sexy it's not where the action is but
like it's a very significant um part I
think like with Hydro like large Hydro
has like large kind of environmental
downsides and I think another kind of
constraint like so there a couple of
other constraints me one is like
geopolitical if you're kind of talking
about damed hydrop power it's often like
a very kind of contentious issue if
you're thinking about Den or other other
area so like that's another big problem
and it's also like very longterm
infrastructure so I think like Hydro I
think like from a technical perspective
like Hydro could play a larger role but
it's kind of I don't think there are
many people that are kind of betting on
like an abundant future with lots of
hydro um or at least I haven't come
across them I think I know exactly like
one charity that's working on hydrop
power
um that's mostly on making a less clear
path in the US and they're kind of
trying mostly to use hydrop making
existing Hydro power or existing dams
more efficient like essentially using
them more to produce electricity do we
even have enough large rivers to to
generate enough electricity by Hydro
that's a good question but it's I
actually don't know the answer because
it's kind of so far out of the overturn
window um one one other thing I want to
say on hydro is that essentially Hydro
is affected by climate change as well
right so like essentially that Hydro is
becoming a less reliable energy resource
essentially as kind of climate patterns
precipitation patterns become harder to
predict and more extreme so I think it's
kind of another reason why it's not like
it's not a major bet that anyone I think
is kind of um really making at this
point okay let's move on to nuclear
energy um what do you see as the
advantages and disadvantages there I
like the biggest Advantage is like
related to energy density right I mean
it sounds like ironic and very
counterintuitive to say this but like
from an environmental perspective like
nuclear is kind of the cleanest uh
cleanest form of energy production
because it's like of those that we have
right now because it's so so energy
dense it doesn't need a lot of materials
it doesn't need a lot of land yeah so I
think that's kind of the clear Advantage
produces zero carbon disadvantages I
think are are well known um in the case
of nuclear so uh accident risk nuclear
waste yeah and also I guess some some
dual use concerns around like nuclear
weapons yeah so I think those are kind
of the the disadvantages and also right
now but that's not a fundamental feature
of the techn ol that's kind of something
of I guess it's a result of social
choice right now it's very expensive and
slow to build yeah that was actually my
my next question would be when I look at
some new nuclear power plant it has
often taken a decade or more to build
and it's gone over budget so so why is
it so why does it take so long and why
does it cost so much to build nuclear
power plants like I think right now I
mean we were able to build nuclear power
plants in France something like four
years right right and right now we're
not able to do this in the west right
now it would probably more take
something like 20 years but so there
there's a lot of variance here that is
like it's not like related to the
features of the technology or like our
fundamental technological ability right
there's like a 5x kind of difference
that's kind of related to regulation
economy societal commitment Etc right
that's kind of where where the
explanation um ultimately has to be so I
think there's kind of lots of different
reasons um I mean one like I guess one
most General one which is not nuclear
specific is like in general in the west
we're not able to build planks right
it's not only that we're not able to
build nuclear plants we're also not in
Berlin we're not even able to build
airports um so so I think that's kind of
like the general class of like there's
lots of General stuff around like
regulation and kind of interest groups
but then there's also like nuclear um
specific stuff right and I think it's
essentially I think the most significant
part is that essentially the the supply
chain uh for for building nuclear in the
west has essentially Fall Fallen apart
right so like we're building things kind
of in in a first of aind um style or
kind of not first of a kind but like
first in a decade or first in a decade
more which is not the way to build like
anything kind of at scale anything
efficiently that's not how France kind
of built the nuclear Fleet right so like
the most Su successful example of
building out nuclear quickly is like
France from the like late 70s to like um
late 80s so that's I think most of the
um
explanation what did France do right I
mean France was in a situation of
emergency so like the 1970s at the time
of like the big oil price shocks and
like France is a country um without
significant domestic energy Supply so
they were extremely exposed to the oil
price
shocks and at the same time they were
already a nuclear power right like they
kind of had like nuclear expertise very
centralized government um um so yeah
they essentially decided okay we're
going to build nuclear as like a
national project and they kind of
standardized it like one of a like build
the same kind of reactor built in the
workforce in a very centralized fashion
if you kind of compare this to the US
for example where like utilities are
kind of really spread out across the
country and like where like
essentially there's like not someone
who's buying like 100 nuclear plants
right there's kind of utilities that are
buying like um one reactor or maybe two
reactors in one plant or something like
that right so like the the the way that
happens was like fundamentally
fundamentally different so these were
very special circumstances and like just
to be very clear I'm not suggesting that
those are transferable to today right
like it's not that the kind of shock or
stress that France was under it's not
something we can replicate and say oh
we're all we're all going to build like
to 80% nuclear in like 15 years um
because of climate change most countries
are not able to do that like
technologically they are but like
politically speaking it's doesn't seem
feasible do you think we we need to
develop new designs for nuclear reactors
do we need to to to move to uh yeah to
better designs um do we need molten salt
reactors or something like this or are
the reactor designs we have today enough
I mean this is I think an active debate
in the like in the nuclear
community and I think like it kind of
depends on how how do we Define need and
less contact right so like I think from
a purely technical perspective right
there's nothing wrong with existing
nuclear power plant so what's wrong is
kind of like when the fact that we're
not able to build them is kind of lack
of societal commitment and like lack of
learning and stuff like that right so
like we can imagine a future where we
buil a lot of that so the question is
can we actually get into that future the
most significant benefit of kind of
advanced nuclear like small small
modular reactors is the
eventually uh it seems more plausible uh
that this is kind of like like or there
there are countries where it seems more
plausible that we're going to build lots
of of small modular reactors because you
can produce them and factories you can
essentially exploit the same learning
curve dynamics that made Renewables and
electric cars and all other kind of
technologies that we were able to make
cheap cheap so that's kind of another
aspect and it's also kind of playing
much better with like renewable
dominated grid so it's kind of more
flexible s like a smaller smaller unit
so I think they're yeah I think I mean
we are like philanthropically speaking
we are we are betting on Advanced
nuclear or small modular reactors but I
wouldn't say it's necessarily related to
like a technological problem with
existing reactors it's more like yeah
the whole yeah I guess one of the themes
here it's not only about technology it's
about the whole like societal kind of
appar around the technology and so the
the small modular reactors would be
easier to innovate on because you would
you would be able to develop one such
reactor and deploy it and get feedback
much much more quickly than you can with
a with a larger reactor where it might
take 15 years for it to to be built and
only then can you go back and think
about what you could have done
differently is it also a question of
potentially you can you can Mass produce
these small module reactors what are the
advantages here so like it is the mass
production right the mass production in
a factory so it's not only the 15E right
like under ideal circumstances you could
also build a large PL that's something
like four or six years like you could
also learn something from large plans
and you could build the same plant
design uh over and over again but it's
much easier to learn and like obviously
it's like a controlled production
environment right so like when kind of
most of the production happens in a
factory I mean obviously some of the
assembly has to happen on site but like
that is where you can really kind of
expect a high learning rates right so
that's kind of yeah essentially applying
the same mechanism by which we make make
other kind of Technologies cheap um to
the nuclear case uh one last technology
I want to run through is um geothermal
this is something that's maybe like
Hydro it's it's potentially a bit
overlooked um but yeah how promising do
you think geothermal energy is so I
would say much more promising than Hydro
but I think also geopal is definitely
having a moment right now and it's
becoming radically less overlooked
traditional geal which is kind of great
but it's very location specific right so
location dependent you cannot do it
build it in lots of places because you
kind of need essentially not yeah you
need kind of good conditions you need
like yeah be close to volcano Etc so
like or essentially you need to be like
close to to to heat Source near in the
ground and then there's kind of like
different forms of like Advanced geopal
and that's a little bit like there's
like lots of different ones it's like
six or seven uh different ones but um I
guess the the one that we've been
focusing on traditionally is what we
what you would call Ultra deep zal or
like a super hot rock ziral where
essentially you're going so deep that
you can kind of make it much less
location dependent and also kind of get
much much um warmer what much hotter
fuel so you kind of get more more energy
density so you get more favorable
economics and that's that's kind of the
idea of like geothermal um anywhere so
if you're kind of able to drill like
five kilometers or five uh down yeah
that could be very promising and that's
kind of like in general this is not only
true for super hot or Ultra deep but
also kind of more generally for like
innovation in
geopal what this does it's kind of
leveraging the advances of the fracking
of the Shas Revolution right so like our
ability to drill has been like strongly
increased um through the through the
fracking Revolution and essentially
applying this to to geero um is kind of
where a lot of the Innovation is coming
from and it's kind of
very attractive
because once you make it work right you
need to solve a couple of material um
science challenges here but like once
those are solved you have like a very
mature labor force and you kind of have
like large economic interests oil and
gas that would be quite interested in
that so in that sense it's kind of a an
innovation that is kind of locked in if
you will right so like it's kind of not
locked out
like yeah but if we're talking about
drilling 5 km down this is not something
you could do in in a in a person's
backyard so this is not as decentralized
as for example setting up solar panels
on a on a roof in a residential
neighborhood no it's solving the same
problem that small modular reactors or
like other kind of clean firm sources
would solve right so it's not this not
about everyone having a super hot rock
thing in their backyard but this is
about solving the hard part um of
electricity decarbonization which is
kind of clean firm resources right so
like not intermittent Renewables but
something that can be dispatched and
that can be used um the entire time I
guess technically this is not a
renewable form of energy but in a in a
kind of practical sense it it will take
billions of years for the Earth's heat
to dissipate enough for for this
technology not not to work so in in
Practical terms it's it's renewable yeah
in Practical terms I think the
distinction renewable are not doesn't
matter because um well I mean renewable
also require lots of non-renewables like
resources to like right like in way so
like the minerals that you need for like
solar and wind and so like so yeah it's
not a it's not a practical thing to
worry about um but nor nor should you
kind of worry about uranium running out
or stuff like that okay we've uh we've
done an overview of of a lot of the
technological options we have if if you
were to to rank these Technologies and
think about you know a plan for how we
might solve CL climate change using a
combination of them where would you
where where do you see most promise um
in in the short term and and in the long
term I mean in the short term it's very
clear that like intermittent Renewables
uh and natural gas will like do most of
the like heavy lifting and
decarbonization in the near future so
like because they are quick to build and
they're kind of quickly expanding right
and like okay in some places also adding
nuclear capacity and Al in many other
places like not prematurely shutting
down nuclear capacity right so like yeah
so those are I think kind of the the
short term and then hydropower uh the
short-term options in the in the medium
run something like well like advances in
geothermal or advances and small modular
reactors right could kind of address
what right now is kind of a little bit
of the AAL of kind of electricity
decarbonization which is kind of clean
firm power right so like that's kind of
why those are still important and like
like worth doing even though like
Renewables right now are cheap and
there's kind of this like seduction of
like only relying on existing
Technologies but like the reason to to
not do that is like the risk that we
talked about before but also kind of the
Energy System function of like clean
firm which right now is kind of not
adequately solved and when you say clean
firm what do you mean well so clean
right means like zero emissions and like
zero pollution and like otherwise clean
so like that includes nuclear that
includes geothermal that includes
um fusion um if it were if it were to
happen and firm here means that it's
essentially it is not an intermittent
resource right it's kind of not like
solar and wind that is kind of so yeah
it can in principle be
run
247 and you will not use it for
electricity 247 but you might use it for
for producing hydrogen other times of
the day but like yeah essentially that
you're reducing what store kind of needs
to do right like it's becomes a lot like
building an energy system that has like
clean firm resources in it like it's a
lot more realistic to get to like 100%
kind of um clean than if you're kind of
entirely betting un intermittent
resources yeah so you think thinking
across the different climate scenarios
it's a it would be a smart strategy for
us to also invest uh in some of these
clean firm Technologies and not just uh
traditional Renewables like wind and
solar okay yeah so I think it's kind of
worth distinguishing two two separate
strands of the argument here even on
kind of a normal kind of trajectory
where Renewables are very
successful like clean firm is kind of a
useful complement right and it makes the
overall system more efficient it kind of
like reduces the like the necessity to
like overbuild um intermittent
Renewables it reduces the necessity of
storage Etc right so like the case for
clean firm is not entirely like hedging
one but then there's also kind of the
the hedging one which is like I think we
talked about this before right like um
if we kind of wake up in 2040 and like
our situation looks much worse than
we're thinking now like what has gone
wrong well one of the main things that
that could have gone wrong is that like
expanding solar inwi was much harder and
in that sense investments in in clean
firm are like aead against that yeah and
there there's a key fact of like climate
that makes the hatching quality
important
and that's essentially like the shapee
of climate damage so that climate damage
kind of like or our expectation of like
how climate damage looks like is that
it's kind of look strongly nonlinear so
like a world of six degrees is like much
worse than twice as bad than a world of
three degrees and the world three
degrees much worse than twice is better
than 1.5 degrees so it's kind of
particularly important right I mean you
need to control for How likely those are
but like it's like even if you kind of
control for for How likely they are it's
kind of important to like favor
solutions that work in situations where
a lot of damage is so those are kind of
right now I would say those are the
worlds kind of north of like 2.5 degrees
like 2.5 to 3.5 like those are
reasonably likely and reasonably more
damaging than the worst cases that kind
of take a lot of the expected damage um
in the in the
function and under those like if you're
in those situations right you kind of
you know something probabilistically
speaking you you know something that is
likely to have happened in those worlds
like one as likely to have happened is
that Renewables will have like um yeah
been more cril than than we expect okay
and I think we'll we'll discuss this
more later thinking about different
climate scenarios and where we should
spend our our money in in uh to kind of
cover all scenarios but before we get
there I want to talk about some
governmental options what could
governments do in order to to help this
situation you mentioned before how
European governments and and California
was able to
subsidize Renewables to such an extent
that they are now quite cheap in general
what's your sense of of how how well
subsidies work would you recommend that
governments uh try to pick out which
which Energy Technologies they favor and
then subsidize those the broad answer to
which this kind of relates to like what
is what how good is the government at
picking winners and like how how far
should the government pick winners I
think like the broad answer is here like
the government was heavily involved in
every kind of important technological
success when it comes to energy and
climate and also like heavily involved
in lots of different failures um so like
on the success right we have like solar
we have electric cars we have wind we
have nuclear we have
fracking on the failure we have stuff
like cylindra we have stuff like uh
biofuels in the US which are like
subsidized because they're kind of big
in Iowa and Iowa is important for
presidential elections like so like you
have like The Good The Bad and The a
kind of all all together right so like
that that's important right it's like
it's not there's essentially no example
of like energy technology transformation
that kind of where government has not
played a huge role um so so I think that
that's something
worth like worth remembering kind of to
to start and it's also there's no
because there's no clear
example where essentially a technology
has been an energy technology has been
brought about primarily
by market forces right so like um so so
like there's demonstration projects
those are often public or like at least
publicly partially publicly funded then
there's kind of well this basic R&D
where like government also plays a big
role demonstration projects and there's
kind of like early procurement policies
like across the entire chain of the um
environment of the Innovation process
government plays a huge role
and I think there isn't really an
alternative to this or like we haven't
really observed an alternative to this
so I think the The View that I would
kind of have is like in general kind of
government is much better than his
reputation because like once electric
cars get cheap then we're all
celebrating Elon Musk but we're like
forgetting the fact that like there's
like huge electric car subsidies that
like made Tesla possible Right like and
I mean there's a similar story like not
to pick on Elon Musk right there's a
similar story for like most other kind
of technological successes at the end
there's kind of a private company that's
kind of doing the last mile that's
getting a lot of the attention but like
before or even at that last stage there
huge huge involvement by the government
so I think that's that's what I can say
to to start so government will make
mistakes but I think the alternative is
not to not let the government um
pick ideally and I think that's what
we're kind of seeing in the United
States right now you're essentially are
trying
to support Technologies at the at the
right at the right level right so like
you shouldn't choose All Tech analogies
and you should also like be humble in
terms of like you cannot pick um all the
winners but right now if you look at the
the inflation reduction Act and the
infrastructure bills like the two major
pieces of kind of climate policy change
in the United States right now they're
essentially like very broad BS unlik
lots of different Technologies and
they're very kind of on the one hand
like the an infrastructure Bill like R&D
driven in the case of the inflation
reduction act more like subsidy and
later stage technology driven like the I
guess they're very strong form of
government involvement but in a way
they're picking a lot of winners or like
some of them will not be winners right
so like they're they're kind of very
very Broad in their their approach to
their credit and and you think that's
the right strategy to to subsidize or to
support uh from the government side
across a wide range of Technologies and
across different stages of technological
development so if we're saying like
history is informative then I think
that's kind of what history teaches us
about like Innovation and energy yes are
there any
research and development into one of the
the forms of of energy technology we we
talked about that you think the
government should spend more money on
should the government be subsidizing at
a later stage of development some of
these Technologies so like I guess the
contextualize the moment that we're in
right so like we're in well yeah mid 20
or mid to late 2023 and like both in the
United States and to less deg El in
Europe like we've seen like major
climate policies uh over the last year
right so like
uh like in the in the United States was
focused on that case right so like the
inflation reduction Act was passed like
essentially almost exactly a year ago a
year before the infrastructure bill was
passed like both of those are kind of
like putting support for clean energy
essentially on a on a whole order of
magnitude kind of different level so
we're now subsidizing or the inflation
reduction act we kind of subsidized
renewable like not only Renewables clean
energy and other kind of clean
Technologies on the order of like 300
billion at least and could go go could
go uh go could go higher than this we
are in a situation where like money is
not the primary uh constraint right now
for most um kind of energy Innovation or
it's kind of like it's it's much much
harder to make that case right like that
doesn't mean we're in a situation where
everything is kind of going great right
it's more that kind of the challenge is
maybe more like stuff like permitting
reform or kind of making those
demonstration projects happening or like
in the case of nuclear reforming the
nuclear atory commission so it's not so
much about um money being the limiting
constraint uh that and like for the
second part of the question should they
support at a later stage yes absolutely
so I think the basic the basic problem
in the discourse I think is that there's
relatively broad support for like uh
basic research and development right
like uh support for that is kind of very
kind of mainstream right like lots of
conservatives will kind of support
investment at B basic basic R&D because
there's a very clear market failure
there that's very well recognized so
it's kind of very bipartisan or at least
there's kind of like a broad kind of set
of people that will support that but
like the like the area where most
failure happen is kind of in the later
stages is kind of like getting the 100
million for a demonstration project so
that's something that historically in
the United States for example has been
hard to kind of get political Buy in to
to fund this work right because it's
also like when you f you fail very
visibly right so like mid Romney in 2012
like started his campaign at the
cylindra plant right like cylindra being
like kind of the example of the failure
of kind of the the clean energy
Investments of the Obama Administration
so yeah maybe maybe explain what
happened there I'm not familiar with the
the is it called cindra yeah so like
cindra was kind of like an advanced
Solar Company that kind of was kind of
heavily supported by the American uh
reinvestment act so kind of the the
small scale version of what Biden did
now like in large with inflation
reduction act kind of like so the
recovery after 2018 the clean energy
spending there and cindra was kind of a
very very public failure uh of of a
company that was kind of heavily backed
by the government and yeah essentially
became the symbol of like okay the
government is really bad at picking
winners right and like that kind of
happened at the same time as kind of the
Shale gas Revolution was playing out
right where like also the government had
kind of played a big role um in
supporting that so it's just like we're
we're very selective and picking our
examples what do you think about carbon
taxes this is a solution to climate
change that's often favored by
economists where you you simply price
the negative externality of emissions
and then you let the market figure out
how to implement the or how to reduce
emissions you do you think carbon taxes
could work so and I guess I've mentioned
this in the beginning but just just to
recap so before I joined
I spent five years working on on carbon
pricing emission trading system carbon
taxes so I'm very familiar with those
debates I mean I think they can work but
I think they will not play like a major
role in kind of the solution and just
like to give a couple of couple of like
arguments why so if you're like thinking
again about kind of the example of like
solar and how solar got cheap so the
subsidies that kind of Germany was able
to kind of that were politically
feasible in the early 2000s in
Germany you could have achieved them
with a carbon tax between like 700 to
900 something in that range dollars per
ton that's an insanely high carbon tax
so like at that point most of the world
had no carbon taxes at all right like
Germany had no carbon tax at all like
the only kind of countries having carbon
taxes were like Scandinavian
countries um and like even then like the
highest carbon tax would be something
like 50 uh dollar at ton right so like
the really kind of transformative price
signal that you need to like drive an
immature
technology you will probably never get
with a carbon tax that's politically
feasible right like you could not it's
not that you could have had the carbon
tax at that level at that time um so I
think that's kind of one reason right
and now we're essentially like now we're
essentially at a situation where like
solar where kind of the difference to
the fossil fuel alternative is kind of
zero in many cases right you wouldn't
need a carbon tax essentially to solve
climate change you need fundamental
technological
transformation and for that you need
like very very strong push and you
cannot get this kind of push with a with
a politically feasible price um so
that's kind of one constraint and the
other constraint is kind of the
international situation so if you were
in a
situation um where you would have a
global carbon tax right like maybe or
Global kind of carbon
price um maybe that would be enough to
kind of induce some some Innovation Etc
but like you're never like it's very far
we're very far from getting there so I
think right now we're in a situation
where it's very clear
that the most significant things that
like individual countries can do like in
a situation where International
coordination is relatively weak are not
about kind of introducing a carbon tax
like had Germany introduced the carbon
tax
in 2005 this would have or sorry in 2005
we got the emission trading system so
let's say if we had like introduced like
reasonably high carbon prices early in
the 2000s would have kind of accelerated
like transition from like German coal to
Russian gas that would have been the
main effect would not have had like
transformative effects uh globally
speaking right so like that's I think
the the really big um constraint there
so
essentially yeah carbon
taxes might play a role once all
Technologies are reasonably close to
competitiveness and then it can kind of
iron out a little bit on the on the
margin but I guess that that's kind of
like not not the point where where it
really matters anymore yeah and just
just to check with you what do what do
you think about planting trees is that
would that work at all is that on the
kind of would that have a a large enough
effect to matter
um you sometimes hear claims about the
importance of the of the Amazon
rainforest for example as a as a as a
way of decreasing CO2 in in the
atmosphere could the government initiate
a large kind of projects of of planting
more Forest would that work so I mean in
principle the easier thing had should
always be avoiding
deforestation because planting trees to
like to have a carbon effect right like
it takes 20 years it's not
instantaneously
useful I mean I guess to I guess to
start with again now we kind of need to
refocus on we're talking here on the
margin and when we talk about trees
everyone loves trees like the person I
meet the most like The Superficial kind
of climate person I meet the most right
like the first like they want to like
they want to plant trees like that's the
first thing that essentially everyone
kind of coming into this conversation
jumps too yeah this is exactly why I
brought it up because I I'm guessing
that this proposal would be extremely
popular with a kind of broad public and
and maybe that itself even though
planting trees may may not be the most
effective thing just the fact that it's
so popular might mean that it's it's
easier to implement and and that could
be an argument for it yeah I mean I
think I mean you would need to do a
certain um insane scale but so if you if
we're thinking about the kind of the
existing solution in the space which is
essentially about like rainforest
protection right and like there we have
kind of an international carbon Market
um around protecting rainforest it's
like called red plus and the basic idea
there is like you're rewarding
countries for avoiding deforestation so
and like the most significant example of
this is like between Norway and Brazil
where like Norway kind of try to like
pay Brazil lots of money to kind of like
yeah save kind of like um DeForest
less and the problem with that is I
think fundamentally that
you're rewarding something you can't
observe like you're you're rewarding
counterfactual like you're
rewarding AO additionally avoided
deforestation which is not something you
can observe right so like you're and so
like that is kind of hard in the best
case and it's like essentially
impossible when you have like Sovereign
Nation States that all can kind of have
their own their own estimates so that's
one of the problems and the other
problem of course is kind of it's not
like the main benefit of of like
avoiding deforestation comes from the
long term again right so like but you
can't really have like credible um
credible commitments over like decades
in terms of protecting trees so like
it's a solution that like looks
seductively simple but kind of in
practice kind of doesn't work yeah so
like that's kind of the case for
avoiding deforestation and for planting
trees yeah I mean you need to do this on
a extremely massive scale and like a not
going to have large effects kind of um
in the in the short term yeah are there
any other non-technological options that
you like or that you find promising
there's lots of other things we can do
right so like I think one thing um that
we should talk about briefly would be
climate Finance so which is essentially
the idea of like
incentivizing lower income countries for
like building or like paying essentially
paying more clean energy um
infrastructure yeah in principle that's
one of the things that you would expect
if we had a global carbon market right
because like ating ating emissions
should be cheaper in a lower income
country um so that's another approach
kind of has suffered from many of the
problems I've now talked about with
regards to with regards to to Rainforest
protection so that's another um approach
that I think we should mention and then
there's kind of when you're kind of in a
situation where you have a lot of growth
happening right so if you're kind of an
emerging Asia right now
there is a lot of variance and like how
emission intensive that that growth can
be so like we've just hired um a carbon
lockin specialist who will like she will
kind of look at what what are the
interventions we can do there but like
if you kind of look at the literature
you can kind of see like clear
differences related to yeah like how how
are cities being built and these kind of
um things like kind of sh essentially
shaping long run behavioral patterns by
like different forms of of
infrastructure Investments yeah and and
you mentioned uh supporting Innovation
or innovation policy I mean that's kind
of ties to what we've talked about
before right which is like the
government is essential for
technological
transformation what the
government does can be affected by
advocacy you can kind of fund through
like where you can fund a charity to do
this kind of work and it is it locks it
kind of sols for this like what I
described as like the central conundrum
of climate policy right that kind of
essentially the US the EU have like way
more leverage through Innovation on like
Global emission outcomes than like
through their territorial emissions so
you have this potential for trajectory
changing Dynamics right that we've kind
of been discussing with the with the
example of solar electric cars Etc that
relatively small changes in the world
like in the the last in the grand scheme
of things right like California
aggressively supporting electric cars or
Denmark aggressively supporting wind
power these are like small changes in
the world but like huge uh long-term
consequences so I think that's kind of
the thing and like the other things that
I would mention uh so like kind of on
the on the carbon carbon lock inside
would be stuff like yeah essentially
regulatory um reform right in the in the
US this would be something like um
permitting reform which which will
become like a hot uh issue or is already
becoming a hot issue because the the
financing for clean energy is there but
the permits and the regulation is not
there and there're similar similar
issues in like um emerging emerging
economies uh so it's not all about uh
technological innovation not at all
right it's also about like um yeah
shaping the regulatory Frameworks Etc
and here you're using some U amount of
money in order to influence a much
bigger amount of money basically you're
using philanthropic dollars to influence
the dollars or the the money spent by
governments yeah so for everything that
we're kind of funding and there's always
there is always kind of advocacy in the
broader sense of the term so I'm kind of
I'm saying essentially using
philanthropy to influence much larger
budgets right and like like that
reasoning comes from the fact that like
well government budgets are like several
orders of magnitude like two to three
Artis magnitudes larger um than
philanthropy and also I think what we've
already touched on right like there's
things that kind of essentially need the
government uh even if it's like changing
regulation Etc right so like most impact
focused philanthropy and climate is
ultimately about kind of shaping actions
of the government yeah or other large um
actors yeah that makes a lot of sense I
I do Wonder though are aren't there a
lot of kind of interest groups trying to
get the government to spend money on on
various things and so you might there
might be a lot of competition for
influence over over the the government's
resources when I just talked about like
the the different sizes of the changes
in the world um that kind of relates um
relates to this
so I think that the best case or like
the kind of the highest impact case for
like um philanthropy to have like a
large impact on government policy is
kind of in situations where there's like
relatively little attention right so
like if we're kind of thinking about the
counter example of like the carbon tax
like needs national attention needs like
bipartisan support to be passed
definitely needs a national conversation
like that's probably a situation where
like an additional philantropic dollar
will not make a large difference because
kind of like lots of other money is
involved um but when you're kind of in a
situation where like you know okay we're
going to pass this big climate Bill and
like there's a big National conversation
about we we want to do this the climate
bill but
ultimately like how exactly does this
climate bill look like which
Technologies does support and how that
is kind of I think the sweet spot for
kind of um philanthropy right because
where essentially there's like lots of
political science literature for like
how this kind of works it's what's
called legislative subsidy so there's
kind of special well Charities that kind
of specialize and like um knowing which
legislation would be needed to kind of
um promote a given technology or a given
approach and yeah essentially providing
providing that knowledge to to policy
maker so I think that's kind of a way in
which in which Charities can have a
large influence and kind
of policy fields that are less
politicized and that are kind of like
under yeah that are kind of not not not
super not super crowded yeah let's give
an overview of the different climate
scenarios so what's most likely to
happen with the climate and and
specifically I think we should talk
about the worst cases and and and How
likely those are you kind of look at the
forecast there's something like onethird
probability that we will kind of meet
Global Climate targets so that would be
like limiting warming to to two
degrees then there's kind of about
another third for something like between
two two and three degrees and then
there's kind of another third for
everything kind of above three degrees
from up to like uh five degrees so this
is kind of from a we can we can link
this in the show notes but like that's
kind of from an from an lsse paper that
kind of tried to Tred to estimate those
last year and but like there's different
ways to estimate this but it's kind of
like broadly broadly consistent so like
we're probably not on current trajectory
is not going to meet the global climate
targets we're going to overshoot them um
by a degree or so um at the same time
right kind of the really extreme
scenarios like six degrees or something
like that has have become like very very
significantly less likely compared to
what we believed like five or six years
ago yeah maybe you could describe some
of the effects of the these different
degrees of heating it's it's a bit
abstract when when we're talking in
terms of degrees could you describe some
of the effects of of different degrees
of heating I mean again like this is of
course an area where there's always like
huge uncertainties right so like where
like if you look at the bars like when
do certain phenomena start it's kind of
always like okay this could start at two
degrees so could start at 4.5 degrees um
I mean the thing that we can of like
right now we're kind of in a situation
where we and where can essentially see
climate change in our daily lives right
where like the temperature extremes have
clearly um changed also like where like
many not all but like kind of many kind
of natural disasters have a climate
change signal on there right so they
kind of become more likely or more
intense related to climate change so
that's kind of where we are right now um
it's Bradly kind of I guess probably
think these things have become more more
intense than if you're kind of I guess
if you're hitting two degrees or more
then like Tipping Point tipping points
become somewhat more likely so there
elements in a climate system that either
would kind of have like local
environment effects so like dieback on
the Amazon for example or it kind of
have like Global Climate effects like
shifting Global temperature up by half a
degree or some something of that sort so
those kind of things become um yeah kind
of become happening happening more uh as
we're moving um higher up yeah I think
that's kind of the main things I would
say this is pretty abstract the reason
for that is this is not really what I'm
not really spending a lot of time on
that I'm mostly interested like given
what I'm doing day-to-day I'm mostly
interested in understanding the shape of
the curve and How likely the different
Futures are because because that's kind
of what's relevant for me to prioritize
and so are you prioritizing the worst
case scenarios no um and I'm really
happy that you ask this because this is
a very typical misunderstanding so what
I'm essentially arguing for um um and I
have a talk about this which we can also
link like on the the structure of
climate risk and its implications for
high impact philantropy what I'm
essentially ask uh arguing for is we
treat this the same that we would treat
other problems so like we're essentially
looking at um expected damage right so
like an expected damage is the product
of two different things it's like the
probability of different Futures and how
bad those fatures um would be and right
now
most of the probability Mass so when we
put these things together based on like
current estimates would be like as I
said I think like above like most of the
damage would be above 2.5 to 3.5 but
crucially it would not be in like six
degrees or more because that's like even
though those worlds will be extremely
damaging they have become so much less
likely that there so that kind of the
the degree like the low likelihood kind
of dominates the strength of the signal
so it's not about just focusing on the
worst world it's kind of taking an yeah
an Factor damage and and the alternative
to this that I'm
criticizing is essentially much of the
focus of the climate Community where
it's like black and white like either we
meet the goal of the Paris agreement or
we don't like there's all of this
massive complexity that you talked about
and we're just reducing it to okay on a
two degree trajectory we will need this
and this and this and like that's kind
of I guess in way the wrong question
where do you see the most expected
damage then yeah so and the last time we
run these numbers and we should run them
again this year but like it's kind of I
think in those worlds that are both
reasonably likely and also much more
like significantly more damaging than
kind of the the best case worlds right
so that would be like worlds of like 2.5
to to 3.5 degrees uh right roughly
that's kind of where where the bulk of
the uh damage is so those are worlds
where the Paris agreement has not
succeeded right because me the Paris
agreement's goal is to limit temperature
to two degrees uh there also like worlds
where like yeah some some things must
must clearly have um gone wrong there
also not worlds like those worlds are
not consistent with like super cheap
Renewables EAS easy seasonal storage Etc
yeah yeah and in in those worlds what
are the most promising interventions to
alleviate the the the expected damage
the method here is let's think about
because we're in a situation of extreme
uncertainty about lots of different
things like how much our econom is going
to grow how carbon tens this growth
going to be how will different
Technologies play out how strong will
the climate react and all of these
things are highly uncertain but we're
trying to understand what do we know
about the the structure here like what
do we know what is more likely to be
true in a worse World essentially so
like on the technological level where we
already talked about this right so like
okay a typic like there's kind of two
two typical or two I think failure moods
that people would expect like run is
kind of like Renewables do not scale as
much another would kind of be that um
electrification doesn't scale as much
right so that's kind of related so if
Renewables don't scale as much then like
the clean firm power sources that we
talked about right those are kind of
we're going to play a relatively larger
role so like a significant part of the
motivation of like investing in
geothermal investing in advanced nuclear
kind of comes not all of it but like
comes from that
um there's of course also like other
aspects to this right it's not only
about the choice of energy technology
it's also about like different kinds of
solutions so if you're kind of thinking
about those Futures like those are not
Futures where as I said like
International cooperation on climate
like being on a great shape is not
consistent with being in a 3.5
world so that means that things that
kind of maybe look very good in the best
case right like if the best case is kind
of like the case that we're in right now
or probably even better let's say saving
trees in the Amazon like if we could
kind of get this to work right like even
if that were very cheap in the best case
where we solve this regulatory problem
that so far we were not able to solve
now that's not going to work in this
kind of world right so so so that's I
think something that's kind of
contraindicated in this case right so
it's kind of like this will look worse
and similarly if you kind of think about
the structure of the world economy like
and kind of like the F future
predictions you probably have like more
of the higher warming worlds are like um
in situations where like emerging
economies have been growing very
strongly right so like um yeah we're gu
like let's say Africa has kind of
growing and growing very strongly so it
also tells us something about like
Regional prioritization at some level I
think actually that's a that's a great
segue to where I would like to to um to
end this conversation by talking about
kind of interactions between climates
and and other areas we could call them
what are the tradeoffs between economic
development and Emissions yeah so that
depends on where you are with regards to
Economic Development so there's a very
strong relationship between economic
development or human development more
generally and use of energy and that's
like not like a One Direction causation
right so like we shouldn't say like more
energy causes more development but we
should say that it would be very
surprising that the world gets a lot
richer without using a lot more energy
so so I think that's very clear and like
there there's um yeah papers on that
that show this very clearly and like
like kind of really really strong kind
of relationship and the relationship is
much much stronger in the earlier part
of the latter right so like um High
income countries right now now are able
to grow without growing their emissions
right so there's like um about 20 25
countries or so that have been able to
grow over the last decade grow their GDP
without growing their emissions what
would be kind of like the the weak kind
of condition of decoupling right it's
kind of not doesn't mean they will meet
their climate goals but it kind of means
that kind of growth is kind of possible
without increasing
emissions but that is not true on the
the lower end right and like broadly for
for three
reasons if you're kind of very energy
poor then like uh so if you can kind of
save more energy like Energy Efficiency
gains Etc we'll just use like probably
translate into into more energy use I
think that's kind of one reason there's
two other ones so one is kind of like
earlier economic development is kind of
more more carbon intensive right so it
requires stuff like that requires lot of
Steel and cement the kind of stuff
that's kind of um hard to decarb cariz
right now or which we actually have not
decarbonized to this point at like um
reasonable cost so that's kind of
another um aspect to this um yeah so
that essentially you're doing lots of
infrastructure Investments that are that
are very early and of course also like
the willingness to pay for climate
policy is like um very low and rightly
so very low if you're in a in a very
energy poor context right if you're in
India and you have like 400 million
people without access to electricity
then like the first thing that you're
thinking about is not implementing a
carbon tax and so we mentioned one very
large um benefit of using less oil and
coal which is to which is a decrease in
air pollution do you think there are
other additional benefits um here I'm
thinking in terms of Greater food
stability or less conflict or um
something like that I would call it the
more sophisticated case about caring
about climate change it's probably less
about like extreme weather events and
the like the direct impacts of extreme
weather events but more like political
instability and conflict especially in
places that are heavily dependent on
like um well environmental conditions
right right so if you're kind of in
subsaharan Africa and you have like
rainfed agriculture like that is
probably the most likely case where you
can get social
destabilization because of climate
change because you're like the
vulnerability is very high so yeah I
think that's kind of an
important effect
this seems like very important from like
like ethically speaking from a
perspective of like okay this is hurt
like climate change is hurting the
global poor um the most and like it's
kind of the most destabilizing um
probably in those in those areas uh so I
think that's a very important effect and
something that I think effective
alterist it's easy for effective
alterist to for to forget that because
in a way if you kind of think about
climate as a civilizational risk I think
I would agree that the the
civilizational risk aspect of climate is
kind of low because it's kind of hard to
imagine a great power War because of
climate change and I guess like if
you're kind of caring about long-term
future like great power Wars are just
like extraordinarily important but kind
of from the from the more near-term
suffering perspective like I think
that's a very significant
effect um and another one that comes
more
from essentially making clean energy
cheap right is kind of so like reducing
energy poverty so just I just mentioned
like I guess 400 million people in India
not having access to to electricity
right so like we're living in a world
where like what we are thinking about
first when we're reducing emissions
right like we can you we can all use a
lot less energy um without like
sacrificing a lot of our living
standards but we're not living in a
globally representative part of the
world um both of us and I think most
listeners um so it's kind of a very
different situation like the average
human on this planet is like energy poor
and like where the human development
benefits of access to more energy are
like very significant um yeah so and
ideally if it's quite clean and cheap
energy that's that's the ideal ideal
case yeah that's a great Point Johannes
thanks for coming on the podcast it's
been a real pleasure thanks for sharing
your knowledge with us yeah thank you so
much yes great to be here